this episode brought to you by policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to let's talk
about the x-men cartoon in fact most
people have it's no secret that this was
a groundbreaking cartoon based on the
hit Marvel comic and not only had all
the action of one-liners that we loved
but it gave us compelling stories
challenging characters and timeless
themes and issues about prejudiced
identity and sacrifice should be told
there's little I could say that could
add any more to what I or many other
fans have already said in the past but
that's why this time I have a little
surprise it's previously on x-men hat
that just goes back to the disc the hat
please give it up for x-men writer Julia
Leigh wall and of course x-men
showrunner Eric Lee walls you two played
a big part if not the biggest part in
making x-men one of the most amazing
action cartoons ever made so thank you
so much for coming on to celebrate it
and not just to sell something now let's
first get off the bat that even though
you oversaw everything from beginning to
end it wasn't your idea to get x-men on
TV whose idea was it who's Margaret
lashes entire list she was wood worked
at Marvel productions she wanted to
expound on the screen no one would put
it there as soon as she became a
president of kids Network she put it on
the air was all her doing this was
obviously a passion project because she
kept taking x-men from Studio to studio
and constantly getting rejected even
when she was the head of Marvel
television which even they weren't
interested it was until she became the
president of Fox Kids that she finally
decided to make the show herself pushing
it hard on this brand-new network if you
want something done right but maybe
that's because studios thought kids
weren't ready for a show like x-men
what would the environment like for
action children's shows back then
everything was softer
what was purportedly an action show at
the time like Superfriends in the Great
Hall of the Justice League there are
assembled the world's four greatest
bureaus I heard you've been a busy a
lien darkside there's a lot of standing
around and chatting and there wasn't
really a lot of serious stakes involved
most of the people involved in our show
were serious comic book fans and felt
that we needed the show that the is
realistic is the comics for now some may
or may not know that there was one
attempt prior to make x-men a cartoon
called Pryde of the x-men but with hokey
dialogue cheesy storytelling in an
Australian Wolverine with the x-men
don't have room for war knee brace this
surprisingly didn't go over well
what impact did this pilot have making
the show and how did the confuse
Canadian for Australian Margaret less
had been working on other shows and she
actually took the budget from from the
13th episode of the series jag extended
to create private the x-men as a sales
tool to show the network's how good an
x-men show could look and the ending
result even though they put a good
budget on it and it's very talented
people working on it it was a bit of a
mishmash and some of the creative
decisions were Worldport this good
little woman colossus like blame around
that time there was a blockbuster kick
coming up called Crocodile Dundee about
an Australian gentleman and one of the
higher-ups above Margaret decided well
that's a big hit film kids are into
Australia make Wolverine Australian so
that's why Captain Marvel is suddenly
from what conduct and so though that was
the kind of creative decision that was
made it was more of a sales tool made by
marketers and as a result story
all together very well and it wasn't
persuasive it didn't make the networks
think that it was time for an expansion
a minor poet for a minor obstacle but in
its way it sort of stiffened the spine
of Margaret and we'll video and Larry
Houston when they dealt their next shot
at putting an x-men show somehow on the
air they were determined to make it
right
well after that failed attempt at a
series how is it that x-men finally got
greenlit and is it true that Margaret
lush actually put her job on the line
yes she put her job on the line right
when she was hired at Fox she told her
boss the first two shows I'm going to
make are excellent that man I have never
met this woman but I instantly loved her
the boss said well then it's been a hit
movie we kind of buy that but I don't
see this x-men thing it's to adults kids
aren't gonna buy you know our
advertisers aren't gonna like it no one
knows who they are no one knows who they
are I don't know what a mutant is I
don't know what a mutant is here you
don't like beauties
well we don't much like you but Margaret
said believe me this is the best Marvel
property out there this will make a
great television show seller bosses will
all the licensee who I hired you I trust
the judgment but if this fails you're
gone this was not a kitten thing her her
job was on the line when she committed
to making the x-man yikes
well with so much late on the table she
obviously got really good people behind
it so how was the developing team put
together well in February 1992 our home
phone number rang and you answered it
and it was Sidney I wonder who's
Margaret's plus his right-hand guy at
Fox who's been with her forever might
work for before people juice the year
before I always wondered why Lydia
sounded like Jubilee we want you
Keeton's the head of the writing and
we've got little widow Mary Houston
being in charge of the art and we're
gonna make the x-man
so obviously x-men had to be something
very different from other kid shows at
the time were there any rules or core
values that you tried to uphold well
Erica I met writing for what was in the
Disney Afternoon Rangers you have too
many good things there were very
specific rules in place about what you
couldn't couldn't do specifically
children's animation then you get the
call for x-men and suddenly those kinds
of rules are out the window and it
really comes down to Margaret lash and
Sydney along I'm longer this was not
Marvel's show they were a very small
company at the time they didn't have the
Creative Cloud on this it was Margaret
and Sydney decided they wanted this to
be a serious adult challenging show that
would be different from any other show
besides the fact that they respected the
comics they knew that Fox was a training
Network and they're trying to compete
with the big guys that had 95% of the
viewing audience at the time so they
wanted something different they wanted
something edgier they wanted something
that would grab people's attention so
when they committed to x-men and Batman
they pulled both staffs do not dumb this
down you know forget about the kind of
limitations you have in the last 20
years working in this business make
these things as tough an adult as the
Congress
the brave are always the first to die as
a writer on the show it happens to be a
half-hour animated show for Saturday
morning but this is live action our
length drama stakes yeah night time yeah
we told our writers you're making a
movie you're making a movie for yourself
this is a group of 30 year olds who are
thrown together and they're fighting for
real stakes and make the show's adult
make their emotions at all right this
for you don't write this down we were
given that green light by the network by
Margaret in Sydney now you mentioned in
your book that even though the writers
seem to be on the same page the
advertisers were not they didn't
understand how to translate the show
into toys which seems very ironic given
how many others still are but with that
in mind what were some of their ideas to
work in product placements in the show
did I hear correctly if they want you to
write in Wolverine shaped walkie-talkies
you did since there had never been a
successful more cool animated show
before they didn't really have many toys
or a much merchandise set up but as soon
as the show is successful we got these
frantic phone calls that can you put
something again we've got some
walkie-talkies
we've got pyjamas we've got some
curtains is there any way you could
sneak them in the show we've told the
people that are selling these things
that don't begin the show do I have a
choice and this is just said know what I
think and it would look great in pajamas
with his face on it and you could have
made peace Nasim Tris use your
imaginations
there was a deal with some I believe
Australian fast food toys kind of like
Happy Meals toys and whoever was at
Marvel and promised them that they'd
show up in the television show and said
we're not gonna have all
we have toy Wolverines in this bedroom
ironically the late great Stanley even
didn't understand the tone of the show
despite him being the one that created
the x-men in the book he bring up how he
wanted to do a live-action introduction
with himself in every episode and
discuss what the lesson was going to be
that they learned by the end because it
weren't so great and hammer man this is
Stan Lee of Marvel Comics warning you to
look around you your classmates your
friends you never know which one of them
may be a mutant as one of your chapters
asks how do you say no to Stan Lee's
great difficulty in front of all my
bosses there was a generational
difference
we all loved and respected Stan and
appreciate that he'd come up with the
characters in their early 60s but when
the x-men got reborn in the 70s with
Langley with Len lean as the crisp Padma
John John Byrne they came up with a very
new x-men the early x-men had been
American teenagers all basically dressed
the same and the characters were not
that mistake the new x-men were tougher
older distinct worldly people from all
over the planet the stories from the
mid-70s on were much more adult Stan had
not been involved with the x-men since
1963 and really didn't care for the new
stories and so he very much wanted the
show to be like what he came up with in
the early 60s it just didn't fit
we needed a garage band and he was
telling us how great Pat Boone records
were the tongue couldn't work and I
believed it and all the creative people
believed it but there's such respect for
Stan that we all heard about and it was
a moment that I had to say that look if
you want to stand the supervisor scripts
fine go with that and they'll change
to that one but if you need it to be me
I need it to be the way we've already
worked on it for heaven once now that is
a shame as you mentioned x-men goes all
the way back to the 60s which means tons
of changes over time as well as tons of
x-men how did you choose the characters
to be the main cast there were a lot of
partners so where's Marvel who had its
interest in in their new and some of
their different characters like gambit
and Cable who were just coming out Fox
who wanted to make sure that they were
popular characters another partnering
Frost was Saban didn't much care but
what happened was is a group of us is a
big meeting 2030 people and everybody
threw out who they thought they might be
and we came out with the five or six
four characters Xavier and Wolverine
absolutely a given and in Cyclops we
wanted a balanced robe was fairly recent
but she worked well for animation
instead of thing the artists were
talking you know who could animate well
well characters would fly and may well
so Robin storm and I'd like the leg up
on people there was more fun to watch in
animation than somebody with a less fun
power yes Rome has a way with many and
then what happened there were half a
dozen chosen there at the beginning we
went off to write markings and I went
out to lay out the first 13 episodes
assuming it would only be 13 they would
only be 13 because it only hired for one
season with a little faith it would be
successful it sounds like the same
people who negotiated the Star Wars toys
we find ourselves more and more using a
couple three characters that hadn't been
committed to
meeting one of them was beast who loved
writing for Beast
we put beast in jail and early on my
episode three because he wasn't going to
be a main character we just okay well
he's had a couple episodes we'll see him
again he asserted himself Jean Grae
asserted herself because even though
they didn't think that she was that
commercial a character we found that
everybody in the x-men had a
relationship with her like that with
almost no one else says she became kind
of emotional core so much like in
live-action television show where a good
actor might make a small tear to grow
and grow over the course of the season
some of these characters like beast and
and Jean and even Xavier who they
thought might be headed in the
background they asserted themselves we
needed them to tell the best stories and
so as we wrote we focused on them even
though we hadn't been told to you had
the heart the core that you picked out
for the x19 but Jubilee was chosen as
opposed to keep product as the way yeah
they tried it actually cried and we did
it 90 percent of our audience didn't
know who the x-men were so in the pilot
Mew needed a new person to come in and
that was going
jubilee to find out what the x-men were
all about along with the audience she
did that absolutely beautifully and that
was that was her initial reason for
being with style petite with style a lot
of why these characters worked so well
was because of the kick-ass voice actors
that brought them to life but picking
them wasn't always an easy task as the
original casting sounded less like an
x-men cartoon and more like a Yogi Berra
cartoon the voice talent for financial
reasons was happening in Canada there
was a lag time back then if you need to
forget but the internet wasn't the way
it was right now and things that happen
in one spot you literally had to put it
in an envelope and mail it back and
forth so there wasn't the immediate
real-time ability to say this is right
that's wrong there had not been a show
like this before right and so when we
sent our scripts and our instructions
about the show we wanted to the people
of Canada who Fox had used before for
Beetlejuice and other shows and so there
was a there's a good history there they
didn't quite understand that we wanted a
completely different show
so the first recordings the audio
cassettes we got mailed back very much
sounded like scooby Doo like zoinks
Scoob it's Sabretooth oh it was very
cartoony it was not at all like the
x-men disease seeing all today and all
of us down here in Los Angeles just
collapsed and thought well the show's
done we went up to Toronto sat down with
them and explain we were basically
telling adult dramas we weren't telling
little kids shows and to please have
another run of it and so they understood
so there was a miscommunication problem
some of the same actors read again and
did fine but they also reached out they
thought well we want we want to try
extra hard to make sure we get serious
cast here they reached out to the
Toronto theatre community which
huge live theater live theater and so we
got a bunch of these Shakespearean
actors like Professor X and Magneto and
beast people people who were used to
pull this the stage and really getting
some gravitas into the drama and future
politicians no joke and Nova Scotia
that's what the voice of rogue is now
talk about doing everything so you got
the cash you got the writing all that's
missing is a kick-ass inch from what
went into making that awesome opening
the minute opening was drawn the vibe
there at Houston in Romania those guys
are so amazing that that was basically
just like a draft and a half over a
weekend Larry did a one-minute opening
Margaret lush lieutenant said you know
can you change a few things we'll do
this a small pass on it and what you see
is what the two of them did in a couple
days there's people who couldn't make it
that good in a couple years and music
was coming from a fella who was also on
staff at the bomb filling Rob Wasserman
on staff was getting paid X amount of
dollars per week you know for writing to
tunes writing to leverage it wasn't
giving more it sets up our show in such
a way and we again all these characters
is no one knows no one knows what they
do know those their powers
there's no narration there we considered
that in one minute they show you
everything they show you what the x-men
were in that you'll be done so
everything was set to go until suddenly
it wasn't and it seemingly looked like
big trouble might be on the horizon
we'll go more into that right after the
break but if we're gonna do a commercial
let's do it the x-men way character in
trouble
[Music]
you'll be right back
and the gooey in the reaper well that's
a shame because death really should be
taken seriously like policy genius takes
it seriously wait am I so not
threatening you're actually doing a
sponsorship while I'm here life
insurance is one of those topics that
everybody knows already but do you know
enough about it to be comfortable
choosing a good one honey you're an
insurance expert or a newbie policy
genius created a website that makes it
easy for you to compare quotes get
advice and get comfortable right here
don't ignore me I'm freaking policy
genius is the easy way to give life just
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find the coverage you need
at a price you can afford from there
just apply a lot that policy genius will
handle all the red tape they'll even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company no extra fees no Commission
sales agents just helpful advice and
personalized service and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance this is
all very helpful but please pay
attention to me I am death you're
shopping for disability insurance to
protect your income homeowners insurance
or auto insurance they can help you get
covered fast I know so little about
insurance but when I look at their site
and I compare the prices I feel like I
get a much better understanding of
[Music]
doesn't he sound like that so no matter
how much or how little you know about
life insurance you can find the perfect
policy for you at policy genius.com you
are literally the guy who will be late
to his own funeral really don't know
much about life insurance check him out
and find out why it's so important can I
kill you now
no really genius the easy way to compare
it buy life insurance
[Music]
to our program with all the pieces
seemingly in place it looked like there
was only one element that seemed almost
completely wrong
that little thing known as the animation
rush to start with that had been in
development for about a year yes we had
next minute was really trying to be
different and another thing you and mark
even's decided to do was come up with
rules verse 13 again thinking maybe the
only 13 one of the best 13 stories you
can tell and comic books are sequential
there are stories that go over more than
one book and you can made the bold
decision to tell stories that are go for
an entire season that are not self
contained in a single write which was
actually you know will many inland
gotfox to make to make that it's a big
business decision because what happened
was the first two episodes looked okay
the third one didn't and had to be
redone almost completely you can't start
putting things on the air if you don't
have next week's show ready you couldn't
run for it would be quite disconcerting
if this were to detonate and part of the
problem was first of all the brand news
shows there are all these subproblems we
get when you're dealing with an
animation house another problem was
there was a serious miscommunication or
difference of opinion let's say between
went Margaret leash wanted and thought
was in the contract for the quality of
the show and what kinds of on who was in
charge of producing it for her was
actually telling the people in Korea
that they were going to pay for so when
we saw the first animation come back it
was
really really not the quality things I
get it's one of those moments where you
curl up and say the show is over I knew
with the existence of the x-men would be
revealed to the public one day this Fox
and Saban thought out their budget
differences they got back into it
they started making the show look better
well behind full of rocking chairs again
it's 1992 and things premiered in
September yeah that's when new shows
rolled out that's one of the shows that
were put on the air began their new
series episode and so this was a huge
decision suddenly like well what do you
did you put the first couple episodes on
and repeat them
seven times until the third one's ready
and so Margaret leche made the decision
she said I'm not going to put show on
until it's right she had to go to all
the advertisers who had hundreds of
thousands of dollars in advertising oh
all a couple hundred affiliate stations
that say I promised you this show is
exciting this show I'm pitching you but
it won't be ready for four months so for
four months you're going to show reruns
you're gonna lose money it's not going
to be right but when it comes out in
January it'll be worth it
share your insurance can handle it but
you all worked around what at the time
seemed like a step backwards but
actually turned out was a blessing in
disguise she had two good episodes she
said wait a minute let's get the fans
into this and get them excited about
January let's show them in October and
then we did and that's why there was a
sneak preview we watch a sneak preview
of x-men makes Pentagon Fox but the
sneak preview also happened on Halloween
1982 having a great time and it was
treated as an expectable but I thought
every kid
is gonna be out trick-or-treating who's
gonna be home to watch an animated show
on pants were there an improved market
right and to show you how how excited
the fans were about the show they had a
Fox Kids Club write-in campaign thing
what's your favorite show on fire
Network
kids what are the shows you chose for
the Fox Kids TV take over killing me
x-men got more votes and all the other
shows put together so they reshow the
pile of the four verse 2 episodes again
in November in November on Thanksgiving
and so it hit show twice before the
official premiere in January at an El
Cajon just say I like a lot of kids at
the time was blown away by the preview
and sucked in by all the other episodes
that followed what was your reaction
seeing that all the hard work and
risk-taking not only paid off but gave
Fox kids its biggest show at the time it
didn't feel real just because at that
time again the internet didn't exist
there was no real-time response or
reaction that that we could gauge
sitting at our desks with our computers
I went to the studio one day box of kids
studio from the Fox Network got here in
Los Angeles and just casually mentioned
so how's the show being received what
Penn reaction
Pop's kids club had little postcards
that you could write down what your wife
did you can mail it in Charlotte
bulletin takes me and it hurts me to a
hallway the hallway was lined down one
side down the other all the way up the
ceiling all the way up to see me here
with these big crepe things and they
were all stuffed with postcards from
kids who wrote in to say that they loved
x-men and this was we had to get a stamp
if you have an address
writing postcards nut you know a casual
thing of tapping something on keyboard
these days and to see that it made that
made it real for me that the show had
found the audience and I've don't get
much better than then there were
warnings at half the country was
watching it but that really wasn't
tangible to us I think until we started
meeting fans later say it Comic Cons and
got a sense of how the entire world got
a chance of watching the show and ended
up really liking it we were suddenly
that thrown into will come on come up
season two so we didn't really have time
to sit back and appreciate it and can I
also have yeah we're done we were all
look though so so when the show became
successful the minute they found out
instead of having a flop they had a
number one again they had to call us all
up and ask us to come back and work
again security any of us have a truly
secure one and luckily both of us were
available but that was a slightly
awkward moment for them professionally
got bit by a dog too now of course
Batman had more time and development and
was also tapping into similar themes and
ideas but in a different way was there
any kind of competitive nature with them
playful rivalry yeah yeah I mean it's a
very small community here we all know
each other
well many oh and Larry Houston who were
in charge these aren't on our show and
he's got a couple of storyboards for
Batman since it got started
about a year earlier and Alan Burnett
old friend of mine was basically that
guy supervising another of the Batman
show both shows were so thrilled that
they were successful for every five
shows that you end up doing maybe one
become successful
you're both so enjoying that that I
don't think there's much time for
rivalry the fact that we had a good run
there for four or five years we were all
caught up in that both sides were we
give them credit they motivated us
because we saw her the footage about
Batman before we got started and they
had such wonderful budgets and such
beautiful art we don't Eliza to compete
with that we're gonna compete by making
the shows twice as fast paced in fact
there was a specific decision made that
men might have so many scenes in a
22-minute we would have 50 60 70 percent
more we'd be really moving faster faster
faster faster because if you lingered on
the quality of our animation you start
seeing some of the scenes in it but if
we double the amount of story then that
would be our distinction versus Bruce's
the Batman show and one credit also to
Sharon Janice write or editor well with
the first season being such a smash what
were some of the changes you want to
make going forward interestingly they
were worried about the sequential nature
of the first 13 and the possible
production delays it yeah so we were
told we couldn't do 26 in a row or
whatever get around that we would do two
parters four and five partners like the
Phoenix sires and in the second season
we get and had that
with the savage land that they put a
minute of data and the beach once it
felt like a continuation over 13 much
like Batman the animation over the
series went through several different
changes
was this a stylistic choice are out of
necessity money all about the money yeah
yeah I've spawned from the beginning was
looking for ways to do the show for half
the price that we were spending there
was an attempt but begin the third
season with the Lady Deathstrike episode
to try a different nation house at the
Philippine house we did a nice job they
did that as a pitch to see if they might
take over from the Korean studio that
was doing it and do it cheaper they did
a nice job but we stayed with it somehow
Fox had I got the ability to dictate a
big budget cut so many of you remember
the fifth season not looking like the
first four seasons and the reason for
that was that it was sent to a different
production house and the budget was cut
all the weaknesses all the losses that
you saw on that simply came down to it
was the last season they were doing and
they thought they'd save some money we
got trouble
even with the budget cut on the
animation the final episode was
definitely a tearjerker making the
ballsy move of essentially killing off
their teacher and mentor Xavier who came
up with that ending him why that choice
season four you would be given marching
orders this will be the last season
there will be no season five so there's
a four part episode of Beyond Good and
Evil that wraps up season four and that
was to have wrapped up the whole series
and that was to included the sending off
of some of the x-men they're bringing
newer newer x-men to characters to make
the team then she got the call no but
we'd written that tired script which was
like 150 pages for a four-part to
embassy this series 5 x-men get four new
ones and then we got the call tech loops
we need a lot more so change all that
around and don't have anybody even don't
have anybody to join
fake-face run couldn't take a joke well
the thing we got through the actual
finale
there's my decision to tell that last
story you know what would bring all the
x-men that had been involved in the
first 75 episodes all the x-men and a
couple of their most important villains
the most important characters we lived
with for five years what event would do
that well Xavier everybody had a
relationship with Xavier and having him
pass while his friends and enemy watch
were watching him go with love in their
eyes seem to be the most emotional way
of doing it no it's us now yeah just it
never it never occurred to us to pull
back and just as with all the episodes
we just thought what would be the most
dramatic what would be the most intense
way to have this happen and losing
Xavier was it so after five seasons of
Awesomeness I got a no what was your
favorite episode to work out I was a
writer of part one of Days of Future
asked which was very gratifying and a
lot of fun to figure out how to thread
that particular needle by using
character issue as opposed to keep ride
and
and the story idea for what became
Beauty and the Beast
the one where these finds love and
realizes she loves him as well and that
was written by Stephanie Matheson well
it's definitely better than the versions
of Beauty and the Beast that Disney is
turning out recently coming up with a
really effective simple story is really
hard for me it's the hardest part of the
whole business in the x-men's case it
was one man's worth we all take from the
our favorite things and I've been struck
by a number of stories with a similar
theme where say in City on the edge of
forever and Star Trek or in It's a
Wonderful Life what is the effect of one
person on the world what better to
express the reason for the excellence
existence than the show what the world
would be like if nikuman had never
happened
what if Charles Xavier had been killed
and you just leap for joy and you find a
story that simple and that effective
that comes to you that fits with your
group of characters so that was that was
my most satisfying story that two part
episode was itself the jumping-off point
for it became the Age of Apocalypse and
the comic books remarkable couple years
later you yeah especially one man's
worth gets me every time because we've
been linked Erik ters the four seasons
up until this point but then in the
alternate universe where you see sperma
Wolverine are a couple you know of
course they are why are there a couple
of they're supposed to be together it's
suddenly all make sense it just breaks
my heart every time Oh
even the creators are shippers get a
life so with an incredible understanding
of these characters I of course have to
ask which one's your favorite
we just love Beast he was the smartest
guy in the room and we all fancied
ourselves being at least largely as fish
smartest beasts he just was a great
character
or what's in the name that which we call
a rose by any other name would smell as
sweet
in my case my job was to supervise a
bunch of very different people I have
great empathy for Charles Xavier as the
kind of herding cats and being the one
that was responsible for the family and
so I really I really think I got closest
to him and seeing how without you they
probably wouldn't exist what do you
think of the movies I'll say before
excellent the animated series there was
30 years up until that point about x-men
stories and since 2000 with the very
first x-men movie and going on you've
got a billion-dollar film franchises I
absolutely believe that x-men the
animated series is that bridge if x-men
the animated series hadn't happened
there would be no billion-dollar
franchise people fear what they do not
understand mankind has always feared
what it doesn't understand them and also
Margaret less to her credit as soon as I
spent the animated series began to sort
of find its way and hit the audience
hard she lent to the folks at Fox films
and said you need to start making movies
you need to start making live-action
movies about these characters now the
experts off the Year by 1997 and it's
not until 2000 that they finally get
together and make it make a future film
that begat this like I said
billion-dollar Empire on the plus side
the casting is so amazing I mean if we
had sat down ourselves and thought what
world-class actors could we get to play
the parts of the characters would write
in for five years most of the choices
they made from the
these were exactly the ones we would
have made so we were thrilled with that
we're thrilled it took him seriously
they're thrilled that they basically
based the team on the team that we chose
and that made us feel like we had found
that the best way to tell x-men movies
out of the nine or ten of them you know
we have favorites we have ones that you
know we wish had been a little different
but overall we were just were thrilled
to watch all over them and can't have
lived with these characters for five
years without wanting every single thing
that they do to be successful
Logan was oh it was a wonderful tap to
that you have all people of the last
time you saw in the Lakeland wean who
created Wolverine and storm and other
characters he solo bit before he died it
saw the movie and he was very impressed
with it it felt right to him as well
well a lot of teenagers and even adults
for that matter felt x-men captured a
voice that other kid shows didn't at the
time sure a lot of children's media
talked about being an outcast or being
unique but this did it in a much darker
and more creative way and nowadays a ton
of kid shows tried to capture the same
maturity that both you and Batman
accomplished how does it feel to know
you paved the way for so many future kid
shows to be more grown-up and
sophisticated well let me say this it's
an honor just to be acknowledged and
thank you so much for for thinking of
x-men and Batman in those terms all
these years down the road that it had an
impact
my storytelling this approach that it it
mattered to people that's very very
gratifying yeah I mean that's why that's
why we do this because we hope it
connects for somebody and obviously
connected with somebody in the tens of
millions of people that watch and the
people that have attempted similar
series since then when we were kids we
wanted serious stories we wanted to be
challenged and it's good to see the
people are still trying to do well you
understood the kids do want to be
challenged and you did an excellent job
of it
x-men broke so many barriers then no
other show at the time had ever broken
and now most children's action shows try
to recreate it in one way or another
even the funnier ones can be more
dramatic bring up serious issues and not
shy away from the tougher moments x-men
was entertaining but also taught tough
life lessons at a time when studio said
that the show would be too adult and
they wanted to play it safe they forgot
that kids don't want to play it safe
they're interested in things that are
different new and challenging x-men knew
how to always keep that in focus and we
have a great team of smart risk takers
to thank for it
and if you want to know more about the
making of this groundbreaking series you
can check out their book previously on
x-men there's so many great stories
about the making of this iconic show and
you can read all about it in great
detail thank you so much again for not
only being on the show but for also
making a great series pleasure I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I ever met wait a
minute next month is March you know what
that means that's the guy who was
originally with the Three Stooges you
know they just weren't the same when he
was in the group it was kind of awkward
and granted there's not many film clips
of him but I really feel like verbal
descriptions are really gonna play a big
part in this month
well the x-men movie said guests are
interesting to talk about but you know
what fine Henny Lisa stain is gonna be
very disappointed slacks relieved but
you know what let's do it next month
it's packed
[Music]
does a mall baby chili fries
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shutdown this week we're doing the Oak
Park River Forest Food Pantry this is
also part of the video series that we do
call what you can do that shows that you
can volunteer at different organizations
and this one is really wonderful we're
going to show a little preview of it
here to show that you know just what a
great place it is and that you can show
your support if you'd like to donate
well I have the link there if you want
to volunteer you can also go to the site
so enjoy this little preview and be sure
to check out the video and share it if
you can because these are really
wonderful people and they do wonderful
work I'm Michele SAR Kowski and I'm with
the Oak Park River forest food pantry
and how long is this place been here
it's been open for 40 years you know
celebrating the 40's this year our
mission is to end hunger so we do all we
can to do that our biggest program I
think it's now our name people are most
familiar with it is the food pantry so
that's a system where people come in
they shop for groceries they leave with
about a week's worth of food and they
can come once a month
hunger exists beyond the four walls of
this building and so we try to reach
hunger where it is one of the things is
the home delivery project and that is
for people who physically can't make it
into the pantry so a lot of elderly
people disabled people people with
mental health disabilities that can't
come in so we call them up ask them what
they want to eat put together you know
several bags worth of groceries and
deliver it to their home we also have a
program in the summer kids you know that
get free and reduced lunch during the
school year when summer is on
there's no school there's no food for
those kids so we have some variety of
summer programs that are targeting those
children to make sure that they get food
we have church groups congregations of
various sorts that volunteer together so
there are those kinds of options where
you can you know bond with your friends
or your community in a broader way while
also giving back to a
there's so many people there like what
we gonna do today I don't know you know
they can't think of anything and it's
like if you're gonna just be laying
around doing nothing it's like just
coming somewhere and doing something so
easy like you said just packing oranges
or just moving stuff or games it's like
it can be helping people learn more
about what the issues are in your
community I think it's wonderful not
only what what you do here but that just
so many people that want to give and so
many organizations want to give and just
every little thing an individual wants
to give a group wants to give and you
utilize all of it I can just say I had
its kind of different ideas of what a
food pantry was like how I use it I mean
it's like the only thing oh it's gonna
be kind of like a downer place but you
do but but it is very positive it is
very upbeat and there's so many various
ways that people can help out and
volunteer if they want to volunteer or
they want to donate when you look right
the camera and tell them where they can
go online www.opm.gov/openseason
[Music]